a mí
no
[Música]
buenas noches a todos
como veis pintos o desde chiquito pero
hoy no vamos a hablar de mis cualidades
ni de mi físico hoy vengo a contarles
una historia hace dos semanas apenas
hace dos semanas fui por primera vez a
la nasa al kennedy space center en la
florida ojalá así de chiquito me
hubiesen llevado hoy quiero contarles
cuál fue mi experiencia a ti te vamos a
llevar a la nasa pronto tienes pura
pinta de ingeniero de astronáutica
vengo a contarles cómo fue mi
experiencia y como logre conectar eso
que veía ya con los negocios y con lo
que hago día a día vamos a contarles
varias cosas primero este año se cumplen
50 años de que el hombre el 20 de julio
de 1969 puso un pie en la luna abro
comillas un pequeño paso para el hombre
un gran paso para la humanidad pero qué
posibilidades teníamos cuando el
presidente de los eeuu de la época dijo
que íbamos para la luna teníamos que
optimizar nuestras posibilidades hoy 50
años después y se espera que sea el año
que viene vamos a volver a la luna esta
vez para quedarnos voy a contarles qué
tipo de retos y qué tipo de habilidades
necesitamos nosotros tanto técnicas como
blandas para poder cumplir nuestros
retos
primero comunicaciones muchos de ustedes
más de los que creen vieron la
transmisión por televisión muchos otros
no pudimos verla no estábamos ni en
planes en esa época sí los que tuvieron
la oportunidad de ver la primera
transmisión hace 50 años se dieron
cuenta que las comunicaciones se
interrumpían hoy que pretendemos volver
a la luna para quedarnos
debemos tener comunicaciones
ininterrumpida
y eso como para los negocios como cómo
funciona escuchamos que nos decían que
no encontramos la gente adecuada es
cierto yo soy uno de los que usó esa
frase y les voy a explicar por qué
porque una de las habilidades que uno
debe tener para afrontar las industrias
4.0 es hablar inglés y no solo lo
escuchábamos ahora en una charla lo
hablábamos en una reunión hace dos días
debemos hablar inglés esa es la primera
habilidad que los que no la tenemos
debemos adoptar porque efectivamente si
encontramos a la gente que tiene las
habilidades técnicas pero que para
comunicarse tiene esas deficiencias
nosotros en los negocios debemos hablar
entre los otros recursos limitados en la
luna no va a ser como bien nuestras
casas que pedimos un domicilio de lo que
necesitemos y nos llega tenemos recursos
limitados en los negocios
todos los emprendedores que están aquí
lo saben los recursos son limitados y
debemos pensar en todo lo que nos puede
pasar hoy la nasa está desarrollando un
programa de como pueden
reproducir los vegetales y realizar las
siembras allá en la luna o dentro de la
estación espacial internacional debemos
poder abastecernos y aquí les cuento una
historia personal para hacer el link con
los negocios yo vendía en el año 2003 la
última lo último en huaraches en
tecnología para restaurantes donde el
mesero con un dispositivo móvil en esa
época todavía no celular te atendía y
mandaba el pedido automáticamente a
cocina cuando yo comencé mi primera
compañía yo llegaba donde mis clientes
les decía ven a venderte lo mejor del
mundo con esa vaina baja a rotar tres
veces más
la facturación de tu restaurante va a
crecer 7% las ventas van a aumentarlo en
cinco porque todo el mundo va a tener
tiempo para pedir postres y un montón de
cosas y cuando el cliente me decía
muestran eso tan maravilloso yo le decía
me puedes hacer un favor me prestas tu
computador y metemos este sidi en el
computador para poder mostrar un vídeo
que te muestra esa tecnología recursos
limitados yo en ese momento no tengo
como tener los equipos para hacer el
demo después de varios intentos logré
que alguien comprar el sistema y esa fue
la primera plata que usé para comprar
los equipos siempre nos vamos a
encontrar con recursos limitados hoy
varios años después y con casi 600
empleados
todos los días nos enfrentamos a un reto
donde tenemos recursos limitados
en los negocios no hay que dar nada por
sentado en un viaje a la luna tampoco
debemos planear y debemos tener todo el
alfabeto de planes no sirve sólo plana y
plan b qué pasa si nos sucede algo en la
mitad del trayecto entre la tierra y la
luna cómo lo vamos a poder resolver a
qué nos vamos a enfrentar cómo vamos a
además a proteger las vidas humanas que
van en esa cápsula o que van en ese
cohete igual en los negocios y en la
vida debemos planear adecuadamente para
no dejar nada por sentado y en esto yo
tengo una regla en los negocios que
bueno la aprendí después de mucho tiempo
y de fallar en el proceso y es que los
negocios realmente se cierran cuando la
plata está en la cuenta o el contrato
está firmado porque realmente muchas
veces y me paso me llama el cliente me
dice hombre gustado tuve este problema
no sé qué vamos yo te invito a almorzar
hay unos clientes que después
a pagar la cuenta a mí pero necesito que
nos veamos para romper las dos copias
del contrato inclusive así no podemos
dar nada por sentado a mí me pasaba yo
me ganaba el contrato y antes de
cualquier cosa ya había festejado me
había gastado la plata bueno en fin
entonces eso debemos evitarlo no de nada
por sentado algoritmos yo no sé si se me
va a ver el ojo torcido
pero dijeron que se nos iba a torcer el
ojo no realmente no se tuerce el ojo de
vemos dentro de las habilidades técnicas
para las industrias 4.0 aprender de
algoritmos aprender a resolver problemas
es que el algoritmo y también todo eso
yo creo que a mí me estudiaron la charla
alguien la filtró porque todos los
anteriores hablaron de cada una de las
cosas que yo vengo a contarles pero es
cierto es cierto si nosotros no
resolvemos los problemas y no creamos
los flujos para encontrar las soluciones
la tecnología no nos sirve de nada
entonces debemos aprender de algoritmos
no pretendemos ser matemáticos puros el
que les guste la matemática y quiera ser
matemático puro bienvenido pero debemos
encontrar soluciones y flujos de trabajo
a las diferentes situaciones que se nos
da en la vida
ustedes saben cuántos algoritmos tienen
que calcular para ir a la luna la
trayectoria de la cápsula cómo va a
entrar a la tierra en qué posición debe
estar cómo debe actuar
tecnología para poner la cápsula en esa
posición que es donde está el
revestimiento que la cubre de las
temperaturas para poder entrar a la
atmósfera etcétera etcétera etcétera
inclusive ustedes cuando están jugando
con alguien o cuando le tiraban la tiza
al profesor
su cerebro automáticamente pensaba en un
algoritmo de fuerza trayectoria para
poder pegarle al profesor en la cabeza y
usted en mi cuenta se daban lo mismo
sucede cuando lanzan una pelota etcétera
ojo que los algoritmos están ahí no sea
que se les vaya a torcer el ojo
científicos de datos
necesitamos científicos de datos y si de
pronto los nombres suenan rimbombantes
pero no en la capacidad que nosotros
como seres humanos o la competencia que
debemos desarrollar para analizar los
datos que tenemos y hoy lo hacemos
nosotros analizamos los datos cuando
ustedes le preguntan a su esposa qué te
pasa nada inmediatamente analiza y sabes
que te van a matar gente
y lo hacen en la vida diaria entonces
ser científico de datos obviamente
requiere unas competencias técnicas un
poco más avanzadas y más estudiadas más
estudiadas porque las de matrimonio se
basan en la experiencia
en esta para ser científico de datos si
hay que ir al aula de clase pero
necesitamos más científicos de datos
para poder afrontar las industrias 4.0
marketing todas las fotos en la mayoría
son fotos de mi viaje digamos de mi
paseo por el kennedy space center como
nos mercados hoy como estamos realmente
mercadeando nuestros negocios ahora
ustedes me van a acompañar en un
ejercicio que quiero hacer con todos los
que están acá ojalá nos salga bien
estaba en en vivo y en directo a veces
complica
tenemos que mercadear nos ustedes en el
ejercicio que vamos a hacer van a ver
como dos cohetes aterrizan ese es un
gran avance tecnológico que no sé cuánto
de acá han visto el vídeo pero ojo en
los primeros viajes la luna hace 50 años
nada se reciclaba si lo recogían del mar
pero no lo podían volver a usar o
volverlo a usar era demasiado costoso
hoy eso ya no sucede así
por eso los viajes a la luna y los
viajes a otros lados se van a volver más
frecuentes pues van a ver eso en el
vídeo pero qué pasa si no le hacen el
marketing adecuado como lo conocemos
cómo sabemos cómo funciona en las
industrias 4.0 uno de los puestos más
buscados es especialista en marketing
sobre todo en marketing digital y así
como en las ventas el marketing tiene
sus retos yo les dije que me habían
chilián y las marcas tienen sus retos
entonces nosotros debemos generar esas
competencias para poder mercadear nos a
nosotros mismos a nuestros negocios oa
nuestros propios logros
este es clave salgamos de las
habilidades técnicas
y en este voy a nombrar una sola que
para mí es la más importante
transparencia imagínense los científicos
y los ingenieros que calculan estas
trayectorias cuando realizan esos
ejercicios y utilizan súper computadoras
para calcular lo que necesitan que no
expongan sus resultados tal cual les
dieron que no cuenten cómo fue su
proceso de manera transparente y que
mientan están poniendo vidas humanas en
riesgo es por eso que en los viajes a la
luna tiene que haber o los viajes al
espacio tiene que existir transparencia
total yo creo firmemente que en los
negocios debe ser igual y me anécdota y
me mencionaban ahora de la alianza con
junio cuando yo me decidió venir a
nuestra ciudad ellos estaban buscando a
latinoamérica realmente ellos estaban
buscando una empresa de vídeo de esas
empresas grandes multinacionales que
prestan servicios para otros
yo ni era grande ni a la multinacional
ni era vivió o sea estaba digamos en
desventaja frente a mis competidores
cuando ya teníamos todos los números
montados del excel a las propuestas de
los proveedores etcétera etcétera
yo decidí mandar todo que fue mandar
todos y mandé la oferta comercial pero
también mandé los costos también mande
el margen que yo me quería ganar las
empresas y los que hacemos negocios
debemos ganar yo estoy de acuerdo hay
que hacer dinero pero irse 100%
transparente era un riesgo que yo debía
correr para poder competir en un espacio
que no era el mío en que resultó llum yo
tenía los mismos datos que yo le había
mandado de los proveedores y la
transparencia generó confianza
y con la confianza el negocio se dio yo
quiero que me acompañen en un viaje
listo todos los que estamos aquí vamos a
hacer un viaje pero necesito que nos
sincronizamos vamos a hacer el conteo
regresivo listo pero vamos a ensayar el
vídeo arranca en 5 entonces yo quiero
que ensayemos de 5 en adelante vamos a
hacer un ensayo y necesito que me
acompañen listo 5
[Aplausos]
perfecto no muy bien ahora vámonos pal
que es listo yo bajo el brazo y
arrancamos
cuando arranque en el viaje de la vida
fija tus metas
debes fijar un camino poner full
velocidad en tus motores y despegar
tienes que emocionarse en el camino
tienes que tener claro hacia dónde vas
tienes que planear muy bien las cosas y
sobre todo te va a tocar soltar te va a
tocar dejar atrás cosas que te incomodan
te va a tocar cortar las relaciones que
no te agregan valor y te va a tocar
resolver muchos retos de acuerdo con la
visión que te hayas planteado retos como
los que tienen los que están planeando
ir a marte retos para hacer que los
cohetes se devuelvan a la tierra y
vuelven y vuelvan y aterricen por sí
solos porque porque así como en un viaje
al espacio nosotros en nuestra vida y
con nuestros diferentes objetivos que
cada uno de nosotros tiene sea cual sea
vamos a tener que resolver diferentes
dificultades y para eso para poder
llegar a un lugar seguro
estar de la manera correcta vamos a
tener que seguir desarrollando nuestras
habilidades nuestras competencias
nuestra empatía y debemos seguir
agregando valor como individuos hay que
festejar
cada victoria por pequeña que sea que
esté en la con su equipo reconozcan el
trabajo del equipo reconozcan su
compromiso tengan una visión la que sea
que ustedes tienen en este caso el
siguiente viaje a marte que seguro lo
van a encontrar
recuerden para mejorar tus posibilidades
debes mejorar tus habilidades muchas
gracias